well it was a long time coming not weeks
but really years in the making as i have
uh revealed to you in some vulnerable
and emotionally honest moments on this
show recently that i have long desired
to be a resident of the state of
virginia i've always felt deep down that
i really was virginian even back when i
was living a lie
identifying with the state that was
assigned to me at birth but finally
yesterday i was able to make the
official transition and become a legal
resident of virginia when i signed a
lease to rent a woman's basement for uh
one dollar a month it was a little more
than i wanted to spend but i decided to
splurge a little bit and it was worth it
because i'm now at peace with myself i
feel at home in my body and in my state
and even more importantly yesterday we
had our rally at the loudoun county
school board in protest of their radical
indoctrination of the kids in the
district
the turnout was incredible the energy in
the crowd made it feel even bigger than
it already was
uh unsurprisingly also none of the
opposition showed up
after sending me threatening messages
for weeks i showed you some of that some
of the things they were
saying to me some of the threats they
were making
they all chose to stay home cooking up
their next batch of mean tweets and
disgruntled emails i guess this is a
common theme for people on that side
they'll confront you online
maybe they'll confront you in real life
if they can be confident that they'll
have you entirely outnumbered but
outside of that
they prefer to stay hidden in the
shadows and insulated
this is especially true of the loudoun
county school board itself
i did end up speaking before the board
and we'll play that clip in a moment but
consider the hoops we had to jump
through just to earn an audience with
the royal majesties on the school board
as has been much publicized they
required proof of residence no problem
for me as a man who has been a virginia
resident
since you were in diapers
i mean if you're currently still an
infant then that would be true um we had
to also present uh you know we had our
proof of residence we had to present
outside the building and they also
demanded that we show our ids as well
and then next we had to empty our
pockets and undergo a tsa style security
screening
already the process to speak at a school
board meeting a public school school
board meeting is far more involved and
far more secure than the process to vote
and the whole thing felt quite racist to
me frankly because it certainly would be
called racist if they required all of
that outside of a voting booth
and we aren't done yet because next we
were ushered into the mostly empty
building
and i also have to say the building
where the school board in loudoun county
does its business is enormous like the
size of the pentagon
um
no spectators were allowed to sit inside
the room with the school board no one no
no one could be
in the presence of their highnesses
no one in the public was permitted to
attend the public meeting
some media were allowed inside but most
were outside the building and we were
then told to stand once we got inside we
were ushered along we were told to stand
in certain marked areas six feet apart
single file waiting for our name to be
called
at which point we would have exactly 60
seconds to give our comment
at 60 seconds a buzzer sounds and the
mic is cut off
and for a final indignity and the thing
that i hated the most you had to wear a
mask
no mask no mic that was the policy
all of this again to speak at a school
board
of course as we're standing in the
hallway waiting to be brought before the
royal court we could hear one peasant
subject after another get up there
barely articulate a complete thought
before being buzzed and kicked out of
the room
the school board said before my arrival
the school board said that that i was an
outside agitator and they didn't want me
there because they really wanted to hear
from the parents of loudoun county and
other community members
well that's kind of funny because if
they really wanted to hear from the
community they have a they have an odd
way of showing it
they want to hear uh from the community
for exactly 60 seconds apiece to be
specific
which means of course that they don't
want to hear at all because unless
you're a very polished speaker
and you do these things professionally
you will not be able to say anything of
substance in one minute put on the spot
like that the people who go to school
boards
for the most part are not professional
speakers it shouldn't have to be
that's what made the whole thing a farce
though that isn't even the worst of it
standing in line with the other
community members
i was informed that in the past the
school board has set the time limit for
public comment to 30 seconds
that's only enough time to basically
tell the school board to kiss your ass
which the next time they said it to 30
seconds that's exactly what every person
in line should do they should have 300
people signed up and every single person
just get up there and say you know what
kiss my ass
anyway finally it was my turn with 60
seconds on the clock and a mask muzzling
my face and here's what i had to say
i would thank you all for allowing me to
speak to you tonight but you tried not
to allow it yet here i am now you only
give us 60 seconds so let me get to the
point you are all child abusers you prey
upon impressionable children and
indoctrinate them into your insane
ideological cult a cult which holds many
fanatical views but none so deranged as
the idea that boys or girls and girls
are boys by imposing this vile nonsense
on students to the point even of forcing
young girls to share locker rooms with
boys you deprive these kids of safety
and privacy and something more
fundamental too which is truth if
education is not grounded in truth then
it is worthless worse it is poison you
are poison you are predators i can see
why you try to stop us from speaking you
know that your ideas are indefensible
you silence the opposing side because
you have no argument you can only hide
under your beds like pathetic little
gutless cowards hoping we shut up and go
away but we won't i promise you that
thank you for your time and i'll talk to
you again very very soon
now there's more that could have been
said obviously but those were the bullet
points
the spectacle inside the building was uh
pathetic and and pitiful in in many ways
because of all of this
all of these uh these uh
roadblocks and everything that were put
in our way but it was also a good sign
in another way
because the board was doing all of this
because they're scared and they're
scared and they should be scared because
they realize that they no longer have
free reign to do whatever they want to
do
enact whatever policies they want to
enact
impose their value system on kids
without pushback or consequence
and that's what this whole debate is
really about if you can call it a debate
with the way they've set it up
it was actually it was thrown into sharp
relief during the virginia gubernatorial
debate which as it happens was taking
place
during the meeting not far away so so
not far away from where we were they
were having the um
gubernatorial debate between terry
mcauliffe and glenn youngkin and when
the topic of education came up terry
mcauliffe the democrat had this to say
listen to this the parents had to write
to veto bills veto books glenn not to be
knowledge about it also take them off
the shelves and i'm not going to let
parents come into schools and actually
take votes out make their own decision
you vetoed it so
yeah my parents you've stopped the bill
that i don't think parents should be
telling schools what they should teach
let's you know i get really tired of
everybody running down teachers i love
our teachers and what they have done
through covid these are real heroes that
deserve our respect and you keep running
them down
yeah some some teachers are heroes
that's true i i talked to a few of them
yesterday teachers with moral courage
who stand against the abuse and the
indoctrination of children they're
heroes
teachers in general though are just
people some of them are heroes some of
them are simpering cowards and lazy
do-nothings who got a year off of work
and still wanted more
some are propagandists and partisans
some are much worse than that so it's a
mixed bag
but what you can't do is put everybody
into the bag and label the whole bag
heroes
more to the point mcauliffe says that
parents
shouldn't be telling teachers what to
teach
well then who should be telling them
what to teach
who who should be deciding ultimately
what kids are taught
what they learn
what values are instilled
this is not a question about the rights
of teachers it's not it's not a question
about teachers at all
this is a question about who should have
the primary authority
over children
and there are really only two possible
answers to that
at least their own they're only there
there are only two that are ever given
it becomes a binary choice it's either
going to be
the state
or the parents
mcauliffe says the state the loudoun
county school board certainly thinks the
answer is the state
more specifically they think the answer
is them personally as representatives of
the state
so that can be your answer
that the state has ultimate authority
over children
which again is what this is about
who is in charge of children another way
of putting it is who do the children
belong to
first and foremost
on earth anyway
you know as as uh believers we would say
that the the children belong to god
first and foremost but who who has god
um
given that authority to on earth who has
god primarily entrusted those children
to
the state or the parents
and we know that the state has been
raising its hand for decades and saying
no no it's us it's us give us your kids
and for a very long time parents were
happy to just
even if they didn't agree to sort of go
along with that
and usher their children into the arms
of the state and say hey treat them well
now
i'll trust you to have their best
interests at heart
now i think people are finally waking up
to the truth
and that is a
a very good thing listen hit that
subscribe button right now do it right
now i thank you for your compliance it
is
somewhat appreciated